Моделі програмування — це фундаментальні специфікації, що визначають,
як структурується програмне забезпечення
та виконується. Вони надають розробникам фреймворк
для вираження алгоритмів
та організації коду, часто приховуючи низькорівневі деталі
апаратного забезпечення або середовища виконання.
Різні моделі підходять для різних типів задач
та апаратних архітектур, пропонуючи
різні рівні абстракції
та контролю. У цьому розділі
розглянемо квантові та класичні моделі програмування
і подивимося, як їх можна поєднати для реалізації алгоритмів
вищого рівня.
Почнемо з моделі програмування
для квантового комп'ютера. Одна фундаментальна модель програмування,
знайома майже всім квантовим розробникам, —
це квантовий circuit. Ми не будемо заглиблюватись
у деталі квантових circuit-ів,
оскільки вже маємо багато чудових матеріалів,
зокрема лекцію від Joan Waters.
Лише зазначимо, що circuit складається з
набору ліній — так званих дротів, що представляють qubit-и,
а також gate-ів, що представляють операції над квантовими станами,
та набору вимірювань.
Іще одна важлива концепція моделі програмування —
це примітиви.
Примітиви представляють найпоширеніші завдання,
які користувачі намагаються вирішити за допомогою квантового комп'ютера.
Зараз доступні два примітиви:
Sampler і Estimator. Sampler дає змогу
зробити вибірку зі стану, підготовленого квантовим circuit-ом,
а Estimator дозволяє оцінити математичне сподівання
спостережуваної величини для системи у стані, підготовленому твоїм квантовим
circuit-ом. Остання концепція,
про яку ми поговоримо у цьому розділі, —
транспіляція. Транспіляція —
це процес перетворення вхідного circuit-у
відповідно до топології конкретного квантового
пристрою
для виконання на зашумлених квантових комп'ютерах.
Подібно до класичних компіляторів,
процедура транспіляції поступово змінює
структуру circuit-у, застосовуючи набір проходів.
Тепер поговоримо про класичні моделі програмування.
Існує багато моделей програмування
для класичних комп'ютерів,
але в цьому розділі зосередимось на двох
найпопулярніших: паралельне програмування
та task workflow. Використовуючи ці дві моделі
у поєднанні з квантовими моделями програмування,
можна виразити практично будь-який гібридний
квантово-класичний workflow будь-якої складності.
Модель паралельного програмування
ділить програму на підзадачі, що можуть виконуватися
одночасно. Існують дві основні парадигми паралельного програмування:
паралелізм зі спільною пам'яттю та паралелізм із розподіленою пам'яттю.
Для наших цілей зупинимося на моделі розподіленої пам'яті.
Модель розподіленої пам'яті
використовує незалежні процеси на окремих ядрах
або вузлах, де кожен процес має власну пам'ять,
а комунікація відбувається через передачу повідомлень. Є
кілька концепцій, які варто знати.
Перша — це процес,
незалежний екземпляр програми,
що виконується на окремому ядрі.
Також є rank — унікальний ідентифікатор процесу,
і є модель
Single Program Multiple Data —
це модель абстракції,
при якій один екземпляр програми
розподіляється на кілька вузлів,
тобто вихідний код однаковий,
але дані на цих вузлах — різні.
Виконання в моделі паралельного програмування
відбувається таким чином:
одна програма розподіляється на кілька вузлів
і запускає кілька паралельних процесів.
Потік управління програмою визначається rank-ом,
тобто ідентифікатором процесу,
а комунікація відбувається
через передачу повідомлень.
Модель програмування task workflow
абстрагує обчислення у вигляді графа або DAG,
де кожен вузол графа — це конкретне завдання
або робота, а ребра — залежності та дані,
і порядок виконання. Приклади можна знайти в нашій документації.
Зрештою, послідовність, про яку ми завжди говоримо у квантових
обчисленнях: маппінг, оптимізація,
виконання та постобробка —
це і є модель програмування task workflow,
де всі завдання виконуються одне за одним
у конвеєрі.
Але з task workflow-ами
ми не прив'язані до послідовного порядку виконання
і можемо виконувати завдання паралельно.
Кожне завдання або workflow може бути цілим паралельним завданням
само по собі, тобто ти можеш
комбінувати ці моделі для опису алгоритмів
будь-якої складності.
Спробуймо застосувати деякі з вивчених концепцій
на практиці. Спочатку запустимо простий hello world
за допомогою парадигми паралельного програмування.
Ми будемо використовувати Open MPI —
реалізацію протоколу MPI,
який є стандартом для передачі повідомлень
у паралельному програмуванні.
Спершу нам потрібно підготувати нашу програму.
Тут ми використовуємо mpi4py —
Python-прив'язку
для MPI, і, як бачиш, ми використовуємо rank для визначення
потоку управління програмою.
Тепер перевіримо наш скрипт для запуску завдання.
Як бачиш, ми будемо використовувати два вузли,
по одному завданню на вузол у звичайному розділі.
Запустимо нашу програму, трохи зачекаємо,
і зможемо перевірити результати нашого завдання.
Як бачиш, у нас є логи виводу нашої програми.
Тут ми використовуємо два вузли та два процеси,
що ідентифікуються rank-ом.
Як бачиш, у виводі є
rank нуль і rank один, які використовуються для визначення
потоку управління нашої програми.
Як бачиш, процес з rank нуль надіслав
певні дані процесу з rank один,
а процес з rank один їх отримав.
Поговоримо також про task workflow-и.
Існують інструменти, що називаються
системами управління workflow-ами — вони спеціально розроблені
для запуску складних workflow-ів.
Але щоб не перевантажувати тебе, ми будемо використовувати вбудовану
функцію залежностей у Slurm,
щоб побудувати ці обчислювальні групи.
Спершу нам потрібно підготувати завдання нашого workflow.
Ось той самий код.
Перевага розбиття кожного з цих завдань —
маппінг, оптимізація, виконання
та постобробка — на окремі кроки
полягає в тому, що ми можемо задати унікальні вимоги до ресурсів
для кожного завдання. Наприклад, маппінг, оптимізація
та постобробка не потребують
доступу до квантових ресурсів,
тому їх можна запустити на класичному розділі.
А завдання виконання потребує
квантових ресурсів, тому ми запустимо його на квантовому
розділі.
Тепер скористаємося функцією залежностей, щоб об'єднати завдання
у workflow.
Як бачиш, ми все ще запускаємо
наш sbatch з прапором --parsable,
який повертає ID завдання,
а потім ми можемо передати цей ID завдання
як залежність іншим завданням.
Як бачиш, ми запускаємо
завдання у workflow із залежністю.
Щойно весь workflow завершиться, можемо перевірити результати.
І, як бачиш, ми отримали назад наше значення expectation value.
Також можемо переглянути всі
результати з кожного кроку.
Вони теж тут.
От і все для розділу про моделі програмування.
У наступному розділі ми поговоримо про продвинуті
алгоритми.